[Music]
[Applause]
as we make way for the former
ohio state great jim calling ucla
michigan state as well as drake in
wichita state
he'll be on the call three games on
saturday unc greensboro florida state
usc drake gonzaga and norfolk
state how are you doing on sleep there
jim you doing all right
what is sleep what do you mean
i mean after that game last night went
into overtime
you know we were at mackey arena so we
had to drive back to indy afterwards but
and it was worth it it really was to see
those young men
uh we didn't get a chance to play last
year kind of especially
the first time for a lot of them um
to be a part of it was special now you
had the winners and you had the losers
of course but uh
not getting enough sleep was well worth
it and i know that the headline from
those games last night was what happened
with coach izzo
in the tunnel right at the end of the
first half what did you see what did you
think in the moment
and do you still feel the same way that
you did when you saw it in real time
well i mean you'll understand i've been
covering you know michigan state since
2007. so this is not
the first time i've seen inter exchanges
like that with coach izzo
whether that's with draymond green or
kalyn lucas or denzel valentine
the list goes on and on he opens and
invites that kind of conversation
and that kind of exchange with his
players now i think optically
it didn't look good for people who don't
follow michigan state
and even if they do it's still optically
with a player running off coach grab
player moves again coach grabs
it doesn't look good and to boot you had
some other interactions
within the huddle before that okay so
i know coach izzo i know those guys i
know what the meaning behind it is
so my perception is different than
someone's on the outside who just see it
optically
yeah i understand it and i've known
coach for probably 25 years
and i know this is his style it just
didn't look good
yeah because as you know jim better than
me
you know the coach can love you and and
you know he's so invested and it's so
important and but he didn't he loses his
composure coaches are always saying to
players
don't lose your composure but then you
have coaches who lose their composure
that's a teaching moment hey you want to
grab
gabe brown and escort him into the
locker room you know what happens in the
locker room
you can air out whatever you want to and
the player can even say something back
but not not on the basketball floor or
in the tunnel when the cameras are on
you
no it and and that's the dilemma when
you have a passionate coach and
passionate players like that where
it spills over i think it's spilled over
in two aspects one
that aspect because again
the optics didn't look good for coach
izzo who's supposed to be the one
that calms everybody down in regards to
when things get out of control it's up
to the coach you kind of reign in the
players
and their emotions second i thought by
having too much of that especially in
the second half
it splintered some chances for michigan
state
to be able to take hold of the game when
they had it and not just with coach izzo
but once a player begins to
defend his actions now he's doing it
with his
teammates along with his coaches a lot
of times you don't hear the instructions
that
someone is trying to give you because
you're trying to defend your action
and that's what happened unfortunately
with
michigan state now i'll say this dan the
difference with with this team
also a few years ago with even a cassius
winston or draymond green these guys had
control they were natural leaders didn't
tell valentine
this team doesn't have it so when it
spirals out of control
now no one on the court brings the team
together because you don't have that
one leader that one guy that can do that
like they've had in the past
yeah those are all great points we're
talking to jim jackson the
former graded ohio state spent 14 years
in the nba
14 years right yeah no all-star
appearance
no the closest i got was my third year
of the year i got injured
um jamal and i both were right there on
the cusp but
um um dan marty got voted in as a
starter when he played for the sons and
the all-star game was in phoenix so that
took a flight away so i never got a
chance to play
in that game uh unfortunately so that's
why you don't like marley to this day
right
i can't stand i get out
do you hold it do you do you hold a
grudge against
anybody that you played against to this
day
i mean because what happened to me
happened to me because it was a reason
you know when i got injured i can't hold
that against anybody
at any moment in your career i did
i did i did i might go live um
it was an incident that happened with
tracy grady mcgrady and i in houston
for one of the reasons why i may have
got traded or not i believe it was the
reason but
i kind of i kind of grew up and let that
go
kind of what happened
oh i can't tell you well no it was i got
traded right after christmas
and um i don't know i heard some stuff
in the background about how i got traded
and i didn't take to it too well and i
kind of confirmed some things but uh
i moved on paulie tracy mcgrady said to
join us
bring him in bring him in what do you
remember the best performance you ever
saw
that you witnessed on the basketball
floor colleger pro oh yeah
oh yeah i was i was at the game when
michael jordan hit the um
um six three point was it six three
pointers against uh portland
yeah in 92 so i was i was in chicago
for the combine so my agent and i
went to the game okay so that was i saw
michael jordan play before
um but that was my introduction
really into the league itself in a
championship
form okay that's i think that was game
one or two of that
series and the old chicago
stadium of course you know and it was
portland
clyde against michael it was a
championship
it was just electric inside that arena
and to see michael do his thing that day
that evening was just like i was like oh
man this is what i'm
this is what i'm about to get involved
with that was the best but what happened
that first time you took the floor and
you have to guard jordan
well you know for fortunately well
unfortunately my rookie year
i wasn't there because i i held out so i
missed him before he retired
remember that oh okay that's right so
when i finally got a chance to
for michael to come back that was that
95 season
i i will say this eerie moment
so we get on the court and it's just
quiet now
we're at home in dallas the fans are
screaming but i don't hear
nothing i just see michael and it's just
almost like
when i'm guarding them it was just he
and i on the court nobody else
i mean never had that feeling before not
that i was intimidated by mike because
we
had some games back and forth but it was
just this is the goal this is michael
and that's all i felt and heard was just
he and i on the court did you did he say
anything
oh he talked all kind of stuff what do
you mean i was young and i talk stuff
back you know
mike mike you know he got into his early
on he may say something it depends on
how the game is going
but then he'll nudge you along
especially he may say some things to the
ref about you
but he's talking about you about you
can't guard with something like that so
it's it's like but you but mike what i
found
dan is this mike along like with kobe
and other guys like that
they respect guys who go back at them
and don't back down
now you may not get them or be as good
as them don't get me wrong
but as long as you show that you're a
competitor and you compete
those kind of those guys respect you
what was the difference between kobe and
mike
uh mike didn't take a lot of bad shots
so mike strategically knew how to get to
his spots
and not take a lot of bad shots colby
at times would force the issue
especially when he was younger
okay kobe would would bail you out by
taking some really tough shots and his
teammates would get upset
but michael was so surgical in what he
did
okay even when he was younger he was a
volume shooter
but he didn't take a lot of bad shots
and that's the difference between the
two and kobe i think
learned that as he got older that he
could still get his numbers and points
without jeopardizing the offense by
putting it in a tough situation by
taking tough shots
i wonder about these guys who played in
a different era
you know bird would be dominant now with
the three-point shot
i don't know if magic would kind of
morph into what jason kidd
did and that is jason became a very good
three-point shooter
um is michael going to be a volume
three-point shooter if
he was playing now or is he going to be
like a durant like that guy who can go
mid-range
if he needs to so i'm always curious
about what yesterday would have done
today
in today's game um and the fact you
can't put your hands on anybody
today yeah yeah well let me let me give
you a better one let me give you a guy's
play back in the day
okay and i'm gonna answer that question
let's take steph curry yeah
people always talk about what steph if
he played back in the 80s and 90s
he wouldn't be physical enough to play i
said ho ho wait wait wait a minute
well you had spud webb that played
michael adams that played
mugsy bose that played d brown that
played all guys who are slimmer
shorter that played and you know why
they grew up in that era where they
played on the playground they played in
the alleys they played in people's
backyards they played a physical
game so they grew up playing that way
steph would have been the same way seth
wouldn't have been the player we saw
we see today because he would have grew
up playing the game differently
okay so fast forward if you put a
michael jordan larry bird
a magic johnson in today's game i said
it's about alonzo mourning listen bro
you wouldn't be dominating in the post
in this era because
at the age of 10 11 12 you will be a
five man that would pick and pop
so your game wouldn't be the same
because you grew up
being taught to play differently so
michael
magic bird all would have different
iterations of their game that would have
changed because
the way they grew up playing and being
taught the game
now the attitudes would probably still
be there but the games
would be different on how they
approached how they played
in my mind phil jackson told me a few
years ago
that you know you can't put your hand on
mike he would
he would average 40 a game at least
is that he was close a couple of times
before even even when you could
i mean i think he's already yeah 37 one
year but
he might have averaged 45 again is that
is that you know because i don't want to
be that oh i remember you know the
the my era you know and all that stuff
but wouldn't
could mike have averaged 45 a game
yeah because we saw with wilt when
nobody could guard wilt
now again the league was different you
didn't have the number of teams when
wilt played
maybe 16 at his height you know eastern
and western division
back back then until we get into the 70s
and expanded
but mike was the same way think about it
when he averaged 37 he was still
learning how to play
early in his career okay now you take
away some hand checking a little bit
later
that gives you more free throws okay and
more attempts at the basket
so that's really only if you go from 37
to 45
okay that's four more free throws two
more buckets that's all that is yeah
per game yeah so it's not unrealistic to
think
that he could have been in that 40 to 45
point per game range
we're talking to jim jackson turner
sports he'll be on the call he's got
three games coming up this weekend unc
greensboro florida state
usc drake gonzaga norfolk state give me
the number one seed do you think
uh maybe a little vulnerable
um michigan okay oh no doubt and the
reason why i
say it is because isaiah liver is their
main top scorer is not playing
he had the stress reaction in his foot
and looks to be out
and then as you know at this time of
season
you have an injury like that to a key
player you can't replace them you don't
have time to make up
you know filling the substitution
pattern with guys that feel comfortable
in that position enough at this stage
when it's a one game scenario
you know if this was a big ten you know
at the end of the victim season but
right going into conference
championships
maybe maybe he gets back in heels but
right now
not having him on the floor now
changes the dynamics of how their
offense operates
gives you a big body that can stretch
and shoot it a leader on the floor an
experience
and you can't substitute that so out of
the top four seeds
that's the one because if they get
through the first game against i think
texas southern they may have to face a
tough lsu
team that took you know that really
played one sec championship game against
alabama
down to the wire so that that itself is
a tough matchup if they get there
your junior year you face the fab five
oh yeah
three times how'd you fare
well i like to believe the first two we
dominated
uh the third one for whatever reason
when i go back to
classic sports and it comes on tv the
elite eight game
in overtime we lost and i i keep for
some reason damn thinking that the
outcome is going to change
but it but it meant so i so i stopped
watching it
but you know here's the beauty about
that fab five team and they're
all personal good great friends of mine
i played with chris
sacramento played with juwan in houston
jimmy king was a
rookie he came and was a free agent at
the mavs and jalen and i know each other
well i'm ray jackson
great group of guys but they drew
from the team that we dominated twice in
that season
to a different more confident group when
we played him in the elite eight
and got to overtime and end up losing so
you know just again it just wasn't meant
to be but
yeah that's my they when i played with
those guys
they hung that over me all the time all
the time
all the time i got you for 20 points in
that game
i actually had 24. 24.
yeah over time paulie check and see if
jim jackson's
adding to his stats there yeah i might
be but i swear
mr jackson i don't want to argue with
you but the box score i got you at 20.
in my mind it was 24.
jim you would have won if you had 24.
again it goes back to my classic story
where i look at it
and i want things to be different
that is great you're watching the a game
you know the outcome and you're going to
want
to i'll go yeah
but see that's the isn't that the
definition of insanity yes you know i
mean i'm just saying
you all have it at some point you
weren't in dallas when i came
to dallas to have a shooting contest
against jason kidd
no i was do you remember when
because it was dave jason's rookie year
wasn't it
and he left practice
he he said he got sick during practice
so he didn't have to shoot
uh against me oh is that what you
believe
oh i know that let's see here we go
back then jim back then i could take
jason kidd and eat
he'll be honest with you he'll tell you
that i could absolutely
so oh wait wait wait wait let's get this
correct we were going to show you
i remember this i don't know if it was
his rookie year or his second year
i can't remember the year but so you're
telling me
that he he the professional yes
professional yes said that he's sick
because he didn't want to lose a damn
patrick
this wasn't a passing contest jim it was
a shooting contest
okay but you're missing my point like
i'm the professional
i'm offended that you would think jay
kidd could beat me back then shooting
well that's just like jay kidd saying
well i'm gonna come to
espn and sit in your seat and anchor
you know the show and you decide that
you get sick and leave yes
you know you wouldn't do that if you
wouldn't do that i would sit there and
wait for him i wouldn't sick out
i'm telling you jason kidd sicked out
of practice that day i don't i don't i
don't believe it
jim i don't believe it i i don't believe
it i'll swear on my guys
hey i swear on my guy
jason kidd will tell you that he's sick
he will tell that yes he will all right
okay when you see jason kidd next time
we're in that leg all you need to do is
go hey hey uh
jason i talked to dan patrick he said
that you uh sicked out
didn't want to shoot against him uh when
he came i came to dallas just to shoot
against him jim okay yeah i made a
housekeeper no i believe your intentions
are right i really do
there's no there's no intention no i
believe your intention to come there and
shoot him was was true
yes i was gonna and i believe you really
think you could win
i do believe that oh i could have won
just don't believe the rest of them
why didn't you why don't you text him
since you know him
and then maybe call fritzy back and
apologize for doubting me
i'm a buckeye jim
oh 1 800 can't shoot
but it's funny he ended up being i know
top 10 all time
of three points shots made how crazy is
that and look at what i did for his
career
yeah i motivated him you did that i
motivated him
and brooke lopez yeah jim
okay man man i'm starting to side with
tracy mcgrady right now
you wouldn't be the first
thank you buddy great to talk to you as
always anytime brother all right that's
uh jim jackson
turner sports college uh football
analyst there and he's got three games
coming up this candidate